hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es geht zwar um eine Kleinstpartei
aber das Urteil dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht heute gefällt
hat über die Heimat ehemals NPD das
könnte möglicherweise eine große Wirkung
haben das Gericht hat entschieden es
gibt keine staatliche Finanzierung mehr
für eine Partei die den Staat und seine
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
bekämpfen und beseitigen will eine
Partei die die Würde von Menschen
missachtet die nicht zur ethnisch
definierten sogenannten
Volksgemeinschaft gehören die
eingebürderten eingebürgerten mit
Migrationshintergrund kein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht in Deutschland zugestehen
möchte wir wollen dieses Urteil heute
für euch einordnen und dazu auch auf
eure Fragen eingehen die ihr gerne
stellen könnt natürlich im Stream oder
auch per Mail wir wollen also darauf
schauen welche Wirkung es haben könnte
auf Parteien wie die AFD wo drei
Landesverbände als recht rechtsex extrem
gelten und wir wollen auch schauen auf
die Ereignisse der letzten Tage und
Wochen auf die Demos landesweit gegen
Rechtsextremismus und auch auf das
Geheimtreffen zwischen einzelnen AFD
Politikern und rechtsextremen pozdam all
das soll heute Thema sein aber wir hören
jetzt erstmal gemeinsam in die Reaktion
in die Begründung der
Verfassungsrichterin der
Verfassungsrichterin zum heutigen Urteil
die Partei die Heimat vormals
Nationaldemokratische Partei
Deutschlands NPD ist für die Dauer von 6
Jahren von der staatlichen Finanzierung
nach Paragraph 18 Parteiengesetz
ausgeschlossen die Antragsgegnerin
missachtet nach wie vor die
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
und ist nach ihren Zielen und dem
Verhalten ihrer Mitglieder und Anhänger
auf deren Beseitigung
ausgerichtet für die juristische
Einordnung und all eure Fragen dazu ist
jetzt bei uns der Staatsrechtler
Alexander Tiele von der business and law
school Berlin hallo schön dass Sie bei
uns
sind schönen guten Abend Frau jung Herr
Tiele die Heimat ehemals NPD das muss
man ja dazu sagen ich weiß nicht wie
vielen der Begriff geläufig ist ist also
eine Kleinstpartei sie geilt bereits vor
diesem Urteil als verfassungsfeindlich
sie sollte bereits zweimal verboten
werden doch der zweite Antrag der ist
2017 gescheitert deswegen erstmal die
Frage wieso ist es dazu nie gekommen
aber eben heute jetzt zu diesem Urteil
über die
Parteienfinanzierung
ja in der Tat damals im Jahr 2017 ist
die Partei nicht verboten worden aber
nicht weil sie nicht
verfassungsfeindlich gewesen wäre
tatsächlich hat das Verfassungsgericht
sogar ausdrücklich festgestellt dass
eine solche Verfassungsfeindlichkeit
vorliegt was es aber moniert hat war
dass die NPD zu dem Zeitpunkt schon so
bedeutungslos war dass ein Verbot nicht
mehr möglich war es fehlte also an der
sogenannten Potentialität und in
Reaktion auf dieses Urteil hat man dann
ein neues Verfahren geschaffen dass die
Möglichkeit vorsieht dass man die
Finanzen also sperren kann die
Parteifinanzierung und das eben nicht
mehr zu Voraussetzung hat dass man auch
eine gewisse Größe und Stärke hat und
genau das ist jetzt heute also passiert
die Partei ist also weiterhin
verfassungsfeindlich und kann deswegen
weil sie verfassungsfeindlich ist nicht
mehr von der Parteienfinanzierung
profitieren das ist heute festgestellt
worden es gibt bereits die erste Frage
dazu bei uns im Stream und zwar fragt
sich hier jemand wär es nicht sinnvoller
die private finanzi zu unterbinden
gerade über staatliche Zuschüsse können
diese jah im Esten kontrolliert werden
indem man die Zuschüsse und Verwendung
am besten gesetzlich regeln und
kontrollieren kann die Frage kommt von
Facebook von Sven
odendah na ja das ist eine Frage über
die man sicherlich diskutieren kann das
aktuelle Verfahren sieht das eben
einfach nicht vor und es ist natürlich
auch immer besonders ich sag mal schwer
zu vermitteln dass eine Partei die
verfassungsfeindlich ist von
Steuergeldern letztlich mitfinanziert
wird also von uns allen und deswegen ist
der Zugriff auf die Steuergelder auch
das was vielleicht am problematischsten
erscheint wenn jemand privat eine unter
Organisation eine Partei unterstützt ist
das glaube ich noch mal anders zu
bewerten als wenn tatsächlich von uns
allen entrichtete Steuergelder dafür
verwendet werden und deswegen glaube ich
es es richtig dass man das Verfahren
erstmal auf diesen Teil begrenzt hat es
gab Reaktionen aus der Regierungspartei
aber auch von der Opposition wir hören
jetzt mal gemeinsam rein und sprechen
danach
darüber unser demokratischer rechtsstat
finanziert keine Verfassungsfeinde und
auch wenn die verfassungsrechtlichen
Hürden für künftige Verfahren hoch
bleiben haben wir jetzt ein weiteres
Instrument um gegen Verfassungsfeinde
vorzugehen aber wenn das
Verfassungsgericht uns jetzt die
Möglichkeit gibt unterhalb der Schwelle
des offiziellen Verbotsverfahrens eine
Möglichkeit zu setzen Grenzen zu ziehen
die Verfassungsfeinde in ihrem agieren
einzuschränken dann sollte man alles
prüfen ob das nicht geht und machbar ist
ansonst warne ich davor das
opfernarrativ hier weiter zu bedienen
und zu beflügeln wir sind alle
miteinander gefordert uns vor allem
politisch mit der AFD
auseinanderzusetzen hier wird die AFD
angesprochen also auch von anderen
Parteien es geht grundsätzlich um
Grenzen für gegen Verfassungsfeinde so
haben wir es gerade gehört bei der AFD
gelten drei Landesverbände als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch so heißt es und es
wird auch öffentlich von Politikern aber
auch von JuristInnen Juristen über ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren bei der AFD
diskutiert wie könnte denn dieses
heutige Urteil über die
Parteifinanzierung von der Heimat
ehemals NPD auf was könnte das für die
AFD bedeuten welche Signalwirkung könnte
das haben vielleicht auch
übergeordnet also zunächst einmal zeigt
sich der demokratische Verfassungsstaat
hier tatsächlich mal wehrhaft und
bestätigt dass die Instrumente die im
Grundgesetz vorgesehen sind nicht
einfach nur auf dem Papier stehen
sondern auch angewandt werden können
konkret für die AFD aber gibt sich
erstmal gar nichts aus diesem Urteil
denn tatsächlich kommt
hat das Verfassungsgericht hier
lediglich bestätigt dass die
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit im Einzelnen
nachgewiesen werden muss und hat auch
bestätigt dass es dafür darauf ankommt
dass die Partei gegen die Menschenwürde
das Demokratieprinzip oder das
Rechtsstaatsprinzip aktiv vorgehen will
und all das müsste man also weiterhin
jetzt im Einzelnen bei der AFD
nachweisen der Umstand dass einige
Landesverbände jetzt schon als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingeordnet werden
vom Verfassungsschutz ist ein Indiz ist
ein erster Hinweis dass hier
entsprechende Verhaltensweisen vorliegen
aber ob das tatsächlich ausreicht für
ein Verbotsverfahren das müsste jetzt
sehr genau geprüft werden denn nicht
alles was der Verfassungsschutz
ermittelt ist eins zu eins auch vor
Gericht so
verwertbar wären denn Einzelverfahren in
den Ländern
möglich ja es wird immer wieder darüber
gesprochen dass man doch zumindest die
besonders auffälligen sage ich mal
Landesverbände verbi bieten sollte also
Thüringen oder Sachsen oder vielleicht
auch einige andere juristisch ist das in
Anführungsstrichen Neuland das hat's
noch nicht gegeben und es ist auch
umstritten ob das so geht ob man also
direkt nur auf einen Landesverband ein
Verbot ausrichten darf
das müsste man vorher klären vielleicht
könnte und müsste man auch mal die das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz wo das
alles geregelt ist noch mal klarstellen
dass das möglich ist ich würde mich
dafür aussprechen dass das schon heute
geht aber das ist tatsächlich ein Punkt
der nicht ganz klar ist in der
Rechtswissenschaft in den vergangenen
Wochen hat auch eine Recherche von
Korrektiv für großes Aufsehen gesorgt
und zwar sollen sich dort einzelne AFD
Politiker und Rechtsextremisten in
Potzdam getroffen haben sie sollen
vertreibungspläne geschmiedet haben wie
sie auch in diesen Konzepten von der
Heimat NPD vorkommen mit dabei waren
eben an diesem Abend auch einzelne AFD
Politiker ist das aber zu wenig
natürlich für ein Gericht wenn sich da
jetzt nur einzelne über solche Fantasien
austauschen
ja es ist generell so beim
Parteiverbotsverfahren das ist selten
die eine Handlung die eine Aktion des
das eine Schriftstück gibt was dann das
gesamte Parteiverbotsverfahren trägt das
ist wie so ein mühsames Zusammenführen
von puzzelstücken die D am Ende ein
Gesamtbild ergeben aber da kommt auch
ein solches Treffen natürlich dazu der
Umstand dass hier Parteimitglieder dabei
waren ist natürlich bedeutend insofern
als dass die Partei sich das
möglicherweise zurechnen lassen muss
gerade weil es hier auch um ethnischen
Volksbegriff ging sie haben es
angesprochen der vom Verfassungsgericht
heute noch mal ausdrücklich als
verfassungswidrig festgestellt wurde
insofern ist das ein weiteres
Puzzelstück vielleicht ein kein kein
riesengroßes aber ein ein bestimmtes das
sicherlich auch in einem Verfahren eine
Rolle spielen würde aber alleine reicht
das nicht aus gerade weil die AFD in
Anführungsstrichen uns nicht den
Gefallen tut ihre verfassungsfeindlichen
vor Ziele in die in das offizielle
Parteiprogramm schon zu schreiben so war
das ja heute bei der NPD der Heimat das
große Teil des Parteiprogramms selbst
schon schriftlich verfassungsfeindlich
waren das ist bei der AFD nicht der Fall
dazu noch eine Frage von Ricardo Milos
bei uns im Stream er möchte wissen
könnte man theoretisch auch die Gelder
für die AFD kürzen wenn diese als
Verfassungsfeinde enttarnt
werden also die Parteien genießen so
heißt das bis sie verboten sind das
sogenannte
Parteienprivileg das heißt bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt müssen sie wie jeder andere
demokratische Partei behandelt werden
dürfen nicht diskriminiert werden
das soll gerade verhindern dieses
Parteienprivileg dass man also als
Exekutive vielleicht zu früh sich
einfach einer lästigen Opposition
entledigt deswegen dieses komplizierte
Verfahren das ja anstrengend wirk und
über Jahre geht aber die Gefahr dass man
ansonsten dieses Instrument zu schnell
einsetzt und einfach nur blöde
Konkurrenz aus dem Wege sich schafft
wäre zu groß und deswegen kann man auch
bis zu einem Parteiverbot oder eben bis
zu einer Feststellung wie wir sie heute
gesehen haben auch Gelder also die
Parteienfinanzierung nicht anders
behandeln bei der AFD als bei jeder
anderen Partei eine weitere Frage aus
dem Stream wir hatten es ja jetzt schon
ein paar mal hier gesagt drei der
Landesverbände gelten als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch der
Verfassungsschutz hat das so entschieden
und hier gibt's eine Frage bei uns im
Stream und zwar ein User möchte wissen
wo ist die AFD gesichert
rechtsextremistisch die Dokumente dazu
werden der Öffentlichkeit vorenthalten
warum eigentlich behauptet der
User na ja vorenthalten werden sie nicht
die Verfassungsschutzberichte kann man
ja einsehen wenn man das will ist nicht
unbedingt die schönste Lektüre und da
gibt sich da geben sich eben immer
wieder Anhaltspunkte auch in einzelnen
Reden und in Bruchstücken in
Schriftstücken in Social Media Posts
gibt es Anhaltspunkte eben auch dafür
dass hier doch ein ethnischer
Volksbegriff vielleicht noch nicht
dominiert aber jedenfalls vertreten wird
das ist ein Anhaltspunkt um mal genauer
zu schauen wie das eigentlich von der
Partei so gesehen wird auch der Umgang
mit Minderheiten ist teilweise
sicherlich problematisch die das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute noch
mal explizit auch auf den antiislamis
auf als antimuslimische der
der Heimat hingewiesen auch das sind
sicherlich einzelne Statements und Posts
und Social Media Beiträge zu finden die
das auch bei der AFD naherlegen also
insgesamt viele kleine Puzzelstücke und
ich würde eben dazu raten dass man sich
das jetzt mal in Ruhe anschaut
und dann darauf blickt ob und inwiew
weit das jetzt auch gerichtsfest schon
ausreicht für ein Verbot oder nicht das
ist bisher glaub ich noch nicht
geschehen und das müsste man in aller
Ruhe tun Teile der AFD die operieren
also mit extremen Slogans Björn höcke
z.B der AFD Fraktionsvorsitzende in
Thüringen der spricht von Zitat
gewachsenen Völkern zu denen Migranten
nicht gehören dürften Gegner von höcke
die fordern in einer Petition die
Bundesregierung dazu auf beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht einen Antrag
auf
grundrechtsverwirkung gegen den
Thüringer AFD Chef zu stellen wir
schauen mal auch kurz hier gemeinsam auf
meinen Bildschirm auf diese Petition
whrhafte Demokratie höcke stoppen heißt
es da da gibt es anderthalb Millionen
UnterzeichnerInnen Unterzeichner von
dieser Petition und hier die Forderung
dazu die spannende Frage die wir Ihnen
jetzt gerne dazu stellen möchten ist hat
sowas Chancen oder einfach überhaupt gar
nicht was was bringt das wenn anderthalb
Millionen so eine Petition hier
unterzeichnen also zunächst einmal ist
die grundrechtsverwirkung ein Instrument
was eben im Grundgesetz vorgesehen ist
das haben die Väter und Mütter des
Grundgesetz ist also äh in das
Grundgesetz geschrieben um eben gegen
potenzielle Verfassungsfeinde auch
effektiv vorgehen zu können ich bin aber
eher skeptisch ob es ein wirklich
sinnvolles Instrument ist denn zum einen
kann man damit eben nur bestimmte
Grundrechte entziehen insbesondere
natürlich die Meinungsfreiheit oder die
Versammlungsfreiheit aber andere
Grundrechte bleiben bestehen das gilt
auch für die europäischen Grundrechte
beispielsweise also höcke wird jetzt
nicht zu einer rechtlosen Person der
sich quasi gegen den Staat in keiner
Weise mehr zur Wehr setzen kann und auch
die Staat ichen Behörden können im
Grunde wenig mehr tun als was sie bisher
schon gegen Herrn höcke tun können die
einzige wirklich auf den ersten Blick
harte Sanktion wäre dass Herr höcke auch
seine Wählbarkeit verlieren würde also
keine Ämter bekleiden könnte aber auch
da muss man sagen erstens würde das
Jahre dauern und zweitens ist es nicht
immer zwingend derjenige der das Amt
inne hat der auch die wirkliche Macht
auf sich vereint wir sehen das in Polen
oder haben das in Polen gesehen da war
es auch Herr katchinski eher und nicht
der Minister Präsident der die Zügel in
den Händen hielt insofern ist das
wahrscheinlich eine Sanktion die am Ende
eher dazu führen könnte dass der
mehrtürer Status von den höcke ihm
vielleicht sogar noch mehr Macht und der
AFD auch noch mehr Einfluss am Ende gibt
Einschätzung und Einordnung von
staatsrechler Alexander Tiele vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast
waren sehr gerne wir möchten das Thema
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiten denn es
war viel los in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen wollen also jetzt die Frage hier
auch bei uns auf dem thumbnail wie groß
ist der Druck auf die AFD wollen dazu
weiter eingehen denn am Wochenende gab
es also landesweit große Proteste
Frühlingsanfang titelte die Tatz am
Montag in der Zeitung auf der Titelseite
eine Großdemonstration des bürgersinns
schrieb die Süddeutsche Zeitung über
diese landesweiten Proteste gegen
Rechtsextremismus schauen wir mal
gemeinsam auf die Bilder vom Wochenende
fast eine Millionen Menschen waren auf
der Straße hier Beispiel München am
Sonntag kamen laut Veranstaltern mehr
als 200.000 Menschen hierher so viele
dass die Demo en werden musste ebenso in
Hamburg am Freitag Abbruch in der
Hansestadt wegen
Überfüllung und viele weitere Städte
waren auch dabei dort sind auch die
Menschen auf die Straße etwa in Berlin
100.000 Menschen und auch in der pegida
Hochburg in Dresden was wir gleich hier
sehen werden auch dort waren viele
Menschen auf der Straße und wir können
darüber jetzt sprechen über diese
Einordnung dieser Protest auch die der
AFD bei mir ist jetzt
Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin Höhne
von der Universität Magdeburg schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hallo guten Abend Frau
jung und zwar gab es euphorische Posts
nach diesem Wochenende es gab also auch
Politikerinnen und Politiker die das als
Zeichen einer aktiven Demokratie gelobt
haben also da gab es ganz viel
Reaktionen jetzt auf diese großen großen
Proteste fakt ist wenn wir jetzt
natürlich auch mal bei den Zahlen
bleiben wenn am nächsten Sonntag
Bundestags Bundestagswahl wäre würde die
AFD laut ztf Barometer zweitstärkste
Kraft mit
22%. und auch nach diesen Enthüllungen
über die wir schon gesprochen haben die
korrektivrecherche von den Treffen von
einzelnen afdptikern mit rechtsextremen
und ihren Fantasien über diese
Vertreibung von Millionen Menschen aus
Deutschland ist die Zustimmung für die
AFD hoch freuen sich da jetzt einige zu
früh über diese großen Proteste vom
Wochenende nee ich würde das schon so
sehen dass das eine wichtige zesur in
der Auseinandersetzung mit dem
Rechtspopulismus bzw rechtsextrem mus
dargestellt hat weil wir
Zivilgesellschaft gesehen haben die
aufgestanden ist gegen die Rechten
Umtriebe ankämpft öffentlich mit diesen
Demonstrationen übrigens auch in vielen
ostdeutschen Städten wo die
Zivilgesellschaft wesentlich schwächer
aufgestellt ist als das in
Westdeutschland der Fall ist und es ist
deshalb so wichtig im Kampf oder in der
Auseinandersetzung mit dem
Rechtsextremismus weil
ein ein typisches narrativ im
Rechtspopulismus ist das dass man
behauptet für das Volk zu sprechen das
sprach des Volkes zu sein und ähm da gab
es äh sicherlich viele Demonstrationen
in der Vergangenheit in den letzten
Jahren Monaten Wochen aber wenn man die
Bilder vergleicht die wir am vergangenen
Wochenende gesehen haben dann hat man
doch gesehen dass ähm die Mehrheiten in
der Zivilgesellschaft doch woanders
liegen nämlich in der Gegnerschaft des
Rechtspopulismus und damit bricht ein
Stück weit diese gesamte Ideologie des
Rechtspopulismus in sich zusammen und
deshalb war das ein wichtiges Zeichen
sie haben nach den Effekten gefragt ähm
ja wir haben jetzt bei den
demoskopischen Befragung bei der
Sonntagsfrage noch nicht die großen
Effekte gesehen ich denke oder ist ein
bisschen spekulativ natürlich dass die
äh erstmal auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht
so kommen werden wie sich das eine wie
der eine oder die andere sich das
womöglich erhofft weil es sowas wie eine
Verfestigung rechtspopulistischer
rechtsextremistischer Einstellung in der
Bevölkerung gibt da geht ein Stück weit
die Saat auf auch die
normalisierungsstrategie die der rechtsp
ismus über die vergangenen Jahre
gefahren hat genau diese Diskussion wer
ist die Mehrheit das ist findet jetzt ja
bei uns in Deutschland fast genauso
statt wie in den USA wo es immer darum
geht diese deutungshohheit zu haben wer
ist die Mehrheit ob laut leise oder
schweigend fakt ist natürlich auch mit
22% ist man jetzt nicht die Mehrheit
aber hat eben eine große Zustimmung und
dazu auch viele Kommentare bei uns im
Stream ich möchte einige Vorlesen Katrin
schreibt bald ein Viertel der
Bevölkerung befürwortet diese Partei das
darf man nicht ignorieren das kann
niemand ignorieren dead l sauer schreibt
ich ich werde die AFD wählen und meine
Meinung ist dass die AFD einfach nur in
der Mitte steht und die anderen Parteien
sind auf der linksextremistischen Seite
angekommen und Zoe schreibt wenn die
Regierung es unterstützt oder sogar dazu
ermutigt gegen die größte
Oppositionspartei zu demonstrieren dann
ist das absolut undemokratisch lassen
Sie uns mal genau über diesen Punkt
sprechen was ist dann demokratisch was
ist nicht demokratisch sie als
Politikwissenschaftler wie würden Sie so
einen Kommentar
einschätzen na ja da ist auch
recht viel rechtspopulistische Agitation
dabei gewesen das ist doch völlig
legitim dass man für seine Interessen
auf die Straße geht dafür eintritt ähm
es ist so ein bisschen das Problem in
unserer Demokratie derzeit dass die ähm
Daseinsberechtigung des politischen
Gegners
in Teilen abgeschrieben wird das ist
ganz ganz ganz stark beim
Rechtspopulismus dass er sich hinstellt
und behauptet er sei das einzige wahre
sprachhor des Volkes und im Grunde allen
anderen Parteien die Daseins die
politische Daseinsberechtigung
abschreibt und das ist äußerst
problematisch das ist Demokratie
gefährdend das machen die anderen
Parteien auch nicht und das bezeichnen
wir in der in der Politikwissenschaft in
der Parteienforschung als
parteienpluralismus also dass man
sozusagen eingesteht dass es
unterschiedliche Anschauung in der
Bevölkerung gibt die übersetzt werden in
Parteien in Parteiprogramme und die dann
wiederum sozusagen im politischen
Wettbewerb über Wahlen und in
Parlamenten diese unterschiedlichen
Sichtweisen auch Konflikte austragen und
problematisch ist wenn man sozusagen
diese Unterschiedlichkeit diese Vielfalt
ähm nicht nicht mehr anerkennt und dann
eben sozusagen argumentiert da wird eine
Partei ins Abseits gestellt die 20% hat
wie wir das im ersten Kommentar gehört
haben ein User Markus der schreibt hier
die anderen Parteien die schaffen es
seit Jahren nicht die AFD politisch zu
stellen und die Justiz lämt sie sich
selbst durch jahrelange Verfahren wie
whrhaft ist denn die Demokratie
Deutschland ist
oder ist es Deutschland wichtig als
wehrhafte Demokratie und sagen auch
international in Erscheinung zu treten
das hat viel mit unserer Vergangenheit
zu tun ähm das ist aber auch was
Besonderes das ist ziemlich exzeptionell
würde ich sagen wenn ich mit ähm
Kollegen im Ausland oder mit mit
Öffentlichkeit im Ausland über Medien zu
tun habe und das erkläre das kennt man
an vielen anderen Stellen nicht und ähm
man hat es auch geschafft sich mit dem
Rechtspopulismus auseinanderzusetzen
insofern bin ich auch kein Freund eines
parteiverbotsverfahrens was es am Ende
auch ein Stück weit ähm ein
Armutszeugnis ist wenn nur noch dieses
starke ähm rechtliche Schwert was in der
Verfassung vorgesehen ist gegriffen wird
weil ähm die Einstellungen sind
natürlich weiter da die
rechtspopulistische Agitation die wird
sicherlich geschwächt durch das Verbot
einer Partei wo die Einstellungen sind
weiter da die Menschen sind weiter da
und am Ende bekämpft man damit doch die
Symptome man müsste glaube ich viel
stärker danach suchen was sind die
Ursachen dafür dass der Rechtspopulismus
der Rechtsextremismus so stark geworden
ist und das wäre mein weiterer Punkt an
der Stelle diese Auseinandersetzung
sollten wir nicht allein den anderen
Parteien überlassen in der außen
inandersetzung mit der AFD sondern da
ist die gesamte Zivilgesellschaft und
weitere akteurinen Akteure gefordert die
gesamte Zivilgesellschaft was wir am
Wochenende gesehen haben waren jetzt
viele Städte wir haben es gesehen in
München in Hamburg also im westlichen
Teil von Deutschland dort waren also
besonders viele Menschen auf der Straße
aber auch in Dresden auch das war war ja
bei uns mittendrin haben wir gesehen da
waren mehr als 50.000 Menschen gegen
Rassismus gegen Rechtsextremismus auf
der Straße sie sind selbst in Magdeburg
sie lehren in Magdeburg können Sie uns
ein bisschen besser ein Bild von der
Lage geben gab es einen Unterschied
zwischen Westen und Osten im Osten wo
die AFD auch in sehr vielen Ländern sehr
sehr stark ist wo Landtagswahlen
anstehen Kommunalwahlen anstehen wie ist
der Unterschied West und Ost ja genau
Magdeburg dieses Semester mal keine
Lehre aber ja am Wochenende waren auch
in Magdeburg Demonstrationen
die medial jetzt gar nicht so
stattgefunden haben aber auch dort hat
sich Zivilgesellschaft organisiert ist
aufgestanden ähm und hat gegen ähm den
erstarkenden rechts ähm Populismus
Rechtsextremismus demonstriert das sind
ganz ganz wichtige Signale für
ostdeutsche Städte für die ostdeutsche
Zivilgesellschaft was sich teilweise im
Rückzug befindet in ein defensiveren
Position als in Westdeutschland also
wenn ich das Vergleiche im vorletzten
Semester war ich an der Universität
Münster und dort gibt's ganz ganz
schnell viel Dynamik viel Bewegung wenn
die AFD irgendwo versucht eine
Demonstration z.B zu organisieren
dann gibt's da ganz ganz viel Gegendruck
plötzlich und diesen hat man so im Osten
nicht das hängt auch damit zusammen dass
eben Zivilgesellschaft über die Jahre
Jahrzehnte seit 1990 eben sich nicht so
entwickeln konnte ähm auch nicht
sozusagen solche Wurzeln schlagen konnte
wie das im Westen der Fall ist und was
wir auch sehen müssen das
Zivilgesellschaft in Teilen
Ostdeutschlands
Sächsische Schweiz als ein Beispiel auch
sehr sehr stark über die Jahre hinweg
durch rechtsextreme Stichwort
Kameradschaften bearbeitet beackert
wurde und da geht ein Stück weit ähm für
die AFD de die Saat auf die davon
profitiert dass eben an vielen Stellen
andere intakte zivilgesellschaftliche
Organisationen fehlen dort eben große
Zustimmung was würden Sie sagen ihre
Einschätzung erreicht die Menschen die
da eben ganz klar sagen ich bin für die
AFD ich stehe ganz klar hinter den
erreichen die überhaupt solche
Enthüllungen wie die Recherche von
Korrektiv dass man sich damit
Rechtsextremisten gemein gemeinsam
trifft und da diese Fantasien entspinnt
reicht das die überhaupt das wird man
schon wahrnehmen und das wird jetzt doch
im nächsten me beim Kollegen Thema sein
wie man damit umgeht ä von Seiten der
der AFD oder in der rechtspopulistischen
rechtsextremen Babbel ähm das wird jetzt
aber keinen großen Effekt haben das
denke ich nicht dass ich Menschen
deswegen abwenden von der AFD weil
dieses Thema natürlich das große
wichtige einende Thema ähm aller
Rechtspopulisten aller
rechtsextremen sind also gegen Migration
zu sein
Auswanderung oder deportations Pläne so
war ein ein Begriff den wir gehört haben
dass sie geschmiedet worden sind
Qualität die die neuqualität die ich
sehen würde dass man sozusagen das diese
Forderungen die man die lange bekannt
sind dass man die konkretisiert hat oder
versucht hat zu konkretisieren mit einem
sogenannten Masterplan wie auch immer
dann tatsächlich ausschauen würde dass
man Menschen mit finanziellen Background
mit am Tisch hatte aus der werteunion
Vertreter ähm AFD Vertreter und
Rechtsextremisten das hatte schon eine
neue Qualität und dass das auch explizit
äh Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsbürgerschaft einschloss das würde
ich sagen ist sowas wie
der das letzte Tröpfchen auf dem Fass
gewesen was das fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht hat in einer Reihe einer ganz
langen Reihe von Erkenntnissen die man
inzwischen über die die AFD hat die aber
sozusagen die Initialzündung für die
zivilgesellschaftlichen Proteste oder
Kundgebung am Wochenende dargestellt
haben die Einschätzung von
Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin Höhne
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
waren ich möchte jetzt auch noch mal auf
eure Kommentare schauen ich habe gesehen
da haben einige auch noch mal
geschrieben und zwar zwar schreibt hier
ein User eine Userin wieso ist die
Gesellschaft mittlerweile so gespalten
wie konnte es sich so entwickeln liegt
es am Internet und dem Informationsfluss
wieso war es früher ruhiger das ist
natürlich eine Frage die man immer
wieder hört in letzter Zeit ich habe es
auch angesprochen es ist ein bisschen
wie in den USA teilweise auch von dieser
Diskussion wer ist hier die Mehrheit das
ist ja auch heute bei uns Thema es gibt
noch mehr Kommentare hier sehe ich noch
einen hier fragt sich ein User eine
Userin wie muss man am besten gegen die
AFD Vorgehen ohne dass ich dabei die
Gesellschaft spaltet also auch hier bei
euch die diese Spaltung immer wieder ein
Thema das euch beschäftigt es ist
natürlich auch ein spannendes Wahljahr
was uns hier bevorsteht wir möchten
jetzt noch mal eingehend auf auch diese
Recherchen von Korrektiv zu sprechen
kommen aber auch auf etwas was ich heute
morgen bei uns im ZDF Morgenmagazin
ereignet hat denn dort war
eingeladen ein der AFD Fraktions
Geschäftsführer Bernt Baumann und der
hat dort Aussagen getätigt die sich im
Nachhinein als Rad also als verhamlosung
von
von von Aussagen dargestellt haben so
jetzt habe ich es wieder und zwar ist
bei uns jetzt hier Nils Metzger ZDF
heute Redakteur der hat das Ganze für
uns eingeschätzt angehört mit dem können
wir jetzt darüber sprechen auch über
diese korrektivrecherche noch mal
sprechen niils Metzger ist jetzt bei uns
hallo Nils schön dass du da bist guten
Abend Alisa Nils ich habe es gerade
schon angesprochen also es gab ein
Interview heute morgen AFD
Fraktionsgeschäftsführer Bernt Baumann
im Interview mit Dunja Hayali dort gab
ging es unter anderem um die
Demonstrationen vom Wochenende es ging
auch um dieses Treffen mit rechtsextrem
in Potzdam du hast all diese Aussagen
von Bernt Baumann geprüft wir hören mal
in die erste rein und schauen mal danach
zusammen wie er sich da geäußert hat
darf ich jetzt mal das sagen was das für
Leute waren wir haben im Innenausschuss
des Deutschen Bundestages ganz aktuell
in der jetzigen Woche den
Verfassungsschutz Vizepräsidenten der
anwesend war gefragt ob gegen
irgendeinen was vorliegt gegen keinen
lag und liegt irgendwas vor das sind
keine Rechtsextremisten das ist eine
Lüge das ist eine Kampagne die Fakten
sind falsch die Fakten sind falsch g
alles klar wenn Martin selner für sie
kein Rechtsextremist ist dann Martin
selner martin selner war ein Gast der
auch geladen war das war der einzige
auffällige der gehört aber nicht zu dem
einladenden Gesprächskreis den 2025
nicht den vier AFD nicht den vier CDU
Mitgliedern was der gesagt hat davon
distanzieren wir uns und mehr ist davon
nicht zu sagen so hier bezieht sich Bern
Baumann also auf das Treffen wir haben
schon häufiger an dieser Sendung jetzt
gehabt zwischen einzelnen AFD Politikern
und Rechtsextremen in Potzdam er sagt
die Fakten sind falsch wir haben es
gerade gehört er sagt Rechtsextremist
Martin selner sei der einzig er sagte
nannte ihn auffällige gewesen du hast
das recherchiert wer war noch
anwesend ja die Informationen von
Korrektiv sind sehr detailliert was den
Teilnehmerkreis angeht
und was Herr Baumann sagt dass
ausschließlich Herr Sellner den Behörden
Vorort bekannt gewesen war ist keine
korrekte
Aussage beispielsweise Mario Müller war
ebenfalls anwesend bei dem Treffen er
ist Mitarbeiter eines AFD
Bundestagsabgeordneten und er wurde
bereits im
brandenburgischen
Verfassungsschutzbericht 2017 namentlich
erwähnt dort als Funktionär der
identitären Bewegung einer
rechtsextremistischen graswurzel der den
neuen Rechten und er wurde dort
namentlich erwähnt und mit mehreren
Aussagen zitiert die ihm völkisch
nationalistisches denken attestiert
haben das heißt die Aussage von Herr
Baumann dass Herr selner der einzige den
Behörden dem dem Verfassungsschutz
bekannten Personen war bei diesem
Treffen ist nicht korrekt auch der
einladende
dieses Treffens nah Potzdam war bereits
in den 1980er Jahren in den 1970er
Jahren in
Rechtsextremist rechtsextremistischen
Kreisen aktiv in führenden Funktionen
kam damals in Landes und in
Verfassungsschutzberichten
vor das heißt der Hintergrund dieser
Personen auch wenn Sie weniger bekannt
sind wie Martin Sellner der jetzt in
aller Munde ist war vorab bekannt dann
gab es eine zweite Aussage die du dir
genauer angeschaut hast ZDF Moderatorin
Donia Hayali konfrontierte Bern Baumann
in diesem Interview heute he morgen auch
mit einer Aussage des Thüringer
Landeschefs AFD Landeschefs börn höcke
der war ja auch jetzt schon Thema bei
uns hier in der Sendung und es ging um
dessen Verständnis wer denn Deutscher
sei wir hören zusammen rein wenn man
börn höcke da richtig versteht sagt er
schaut euch ins Gesicht sprecht
miteinander hört euch zu wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann werden wir uns
erkennen sind das also äußere Merkmale
an denen wir uns erkennen das ist doch
völliger Blödsinn
Frau sagt und schreibt völlig das hat
doch nichts mit Volk zu tun was höcke da
meint das doch völliger Unsinn da redet
er doch nicht über das Volk das deutsche
Volk sind alle die den deutschen Pass
besitzen mit gleichen Rechten und
Pflichten da gibt's keines keine
Staatsbürgerschaft erster lassen mich
doch Ausreden keine Staatsbürgerschaft
erster und zweiter
Klasse Nils du hast auch diese Aussage
dir genauer angeschaut völliger Blödsinn
sagt ja hier Bernt Baumann was ist dein
Kontext den du für uns hast zu dieser
Aussage ja hier sind wir direkt in der
kritischen Frage drin die AFD versucht
nun das Treffen in Potzdam und diese ja
völkischen Diskussion in Teilen der der
Partei als möglichst harmlos
darzustellen diese
[Musik]
Rede von Herrn höcke die dort zitiert
wurde ist keine alte Rede sondern sie
ist im vergangenen Jahr im November bei
einer pegida Veranstaltung in Dresen
gefallen das heißt die Aussage dass die
Herr Baumann getroffen hat dass es sich
da
lediglich um AFD Mitglieder gehandelt
hat auf die er seine Aussage bezieht und
nicht eine Definition des deutschen
Volkes ist nicht stichhaltig außerdem
wenn man sich die Rede im Original
anschaut nur wenige Sekunden davor
betont Herr höcke aus explizit dass es
ihm bei dieser Beschreibung von Menschen
die er die man erkennen soll
um eine Definition des deutschen Volkes
geht und wie man in einer möglichen
zukünft
Konfliktsituation von verschiedenen
Teilen der Bevölkerung wie man dort die
seinigen erkennt das ist ganz explizit
völkisches nationalistisches denken und
das ist damals auch breit in der Presse
berichtet worden und dass Herr Baumann
jetzt versucht den Kontext dieser
Aussage zu verrücken
ja ist ein Versuch der AFD einerseits
rechts zu blinken und dann anschließend
ja
so zu tun als ob man diese Aussagen gar
nicht getroffen hätte wir haben die
Aussage original auch da von Björn höcke
wir können die gerne noch mal zusammen
anhören was ist denn das deutsche Volk
überhaupt was ist von deutschen Volk den
überhaupt noch
übrig eine berechtigte Frage was das
deutsche Volk ist was unsere Identität
ist ist vielleicht ein Thema dass man in
einer Vorlesung oder in einem Vortrag
ausführlich besprechen und erörtern
müsste das ist kein Thema für eine
Demonstration vielleicht abschließ nur
so viel
schaut euch ins
Gesicht sprecht
miteinander hört euch zu nehmt euch wahr
begegnet euch und glaubt mir wenn es
hart auf hart kommt dann werden wir uns
erkennen dann werden wir uns finden dann
sind wir das was wir immer waren treu
und Deutsch und eine Gemeinschaft die
die Zukunft erkämpfen
wird bleiben wir noch bei Björn höcke
der hat sich nämlich jetzt auch gemeldet
bei Ex eemals Twitter nach den Demos am
Wochenende wir können mal zusammen auf
meinen Bildschirm schauen da hat er
gepostet er hat also geschrieben zu
einem Foto der Demo in Hamburg bestellte
Massen demonstrieren gegen die AFD doch
bei den in den Medien veröffentlichten
Bildern fallen inzwischen zahlreiche
Fälle von Bildmanipulationen auf warum
haben sie das nötig wo bleibt der
Faktencheck fragt der hier und hier
unten gibt es noch einen weiteren Post
hier das ist der von der dpa also bei
dem Bild was von ztf heute also von
unserer Redaktion veröffentlicht wurde
handelt es sich um ein originales dpa
Foto und dpa äußert sich also selbst
dazu und sagt da wurde nichts
manipuliert du hast dir auch ganz genau
die Fotos angeschaut niils wir können
auch gleich noch mal auf ein weiteres
schauen kannst du auch gerne noch mal
ansprechen was ich da zeigen soll du
hast dich also genau damit beschäftigt
warum die AFD also Gerüchte verbreitet
jetzt in explizit nach diesem Wochenende
und von manipulierten Bildern spricht
von eben diesen vielen Menschen die da
gegen Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße
gegangen sind kannst du uns zu deiner
Recherche dazu und was du aufgeschrieben
hast mir erzählen diesen geforderten
Faktencheck haben wir gemacht und
tatsächlich war es nicht sehr
kompliziert die Authentizität dieser
Bilder zu überprüfen es gab keine
Manipulation keine Anpassung der Bilder
von dieser Szene ähm in der Hamburger
Innenstadt gibt es eine ganze Reihe von
Aufnahmen Videoaufnahmen
Videostreams Fotos aus anderen
Perspektiven und dabei ist sehr schnell
klar geworden dass das Bild authentisch
ist
es ist die innenal oder der der Stein
des Anstoßes war dass die Innenalster im
Hintergrund nicht
im gleichen Ausmaß zu sehen war wie auf
anderen Bildern die von weiter oben
aufgenommen wurden das ist aber rein
eine Frage der Perspektive das ist keine
keine Verstellung oder
Manipulation und daran kann man auch
etwas erkennen wie sehr die äh Teile der
AFD hier sich unter Druck fühlen ähm ein
gegennarrativ zu etablieren und etwas
ähm in die Öffentlichkeit zu setzen
womit man seine Anhänger mobilisieren
kann womit man gegen die Presse schießen
kann die diese äh demobilder verbreitet
über diese Proteste berichtet und diese
Demonstrationen insgesamt in in Zweifel
zu ziehen ähm das äh überprüfen dieser
ähm dieser Bericht
war aber in dem Fall überaus einfach und
auch die dpa hat es wie gesagt
klargestellt deswegen gibt es an diesem
Foto keinerlei Zweifel ich zeig noch ein
zweites dann könntest du es dazu auch
noch mal mehr sagen und zwar wurde hier
geschrieben von Gunner Beck abgesehen
davon dass es sich bei der Demo gegen
Rechts am Heumarkt in Köln mitten im
Januar ein grüner Baum auf dem Foto
findet wie kommt es nur dass laut ai
Check Apps die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer
KI Manipulation bei 92% liegt und was er
damit meint es diese Stelle hier Nils
berichte uns doch gerne etwas zu diesem
Foto daran kann man auch sehen dass es
häufig nicht darum geht wie glaubwürdig
eine einzelne ein einzelner Vorwurf ist
ähm sondern es hauptsächlich drum geht
über Masse einen ja Zweifel zu
hinterlassen dass der Zuschauer dass der
Nutzer am Ende nicht mehr genau weiß was
jetzt eigentlich wahr und falsch ist
denn auch dieses Bild kann man mit sehr
geringem Aufwand überprüfen dem man sich
den den Heumarkt in Köln anschaut und
genau an der Stelle wo diese diese grüne
Fläche im Bild zu sehen ist ist eine
große Außenbeleuchtung eines eines
Lokals dort wo die ganze Fassade grün
angestrahlt wird wo auch der Baum
daneben in grüner Farbe erstrahlt und
das ist das was man dort in den Bildern
erkennen kann das heißt auch diesen
diesen sehr sehr schwerwiegenden Vorwurf
gegen gegen Medien wie wie das ZDF und
und
andere kann man sehr sehr leicht
geradeerücken sehr sehr leicht
verifizieren aber darum geht es vielen
der Poster der alternativmedien die
solche Gerüchte verbreiten nicht SN es
geht darum Zweifel zu schüren dass die
Nutzer am Ende gar nicht mehr genau
wissen wer jetzt eigentlich lügt oder
wer die wer die Wahrheit sagt Nils deine
Artikel die können hier alle die
zuschauen auch gerne nachlesen bei ztf
heute du hast beide Recherchen und beide
faktchecks für uns aufgeschrieben vielen
Dank dass du heute bei uns warst Nils
metzg danke schönen Abend dir noch danke
schönen Abend Dir und natürlich auch
schönen Abend euch denn jetzt ist die
Sendung hier an dieser Stelle zu Ende
vielen Dank für eure ganzen Fragen und
Kommentare super dass ihr so viel
geschrieben habt und wir sehen uns gerne
diese Woche wieder hier bei Z heute live
macht's
gut